So Donald Trump did something in public
yesterday, leaving the White House
for his first public appearance since
the riotous insurrection. Last week,
Donald Trump was heading out from the White House
en route to the US Mexico border in Texas to
tell predictable lies about the wall that was
never built and that Mexico did not pay for.
Let's get right into it. Donald Trump attempting
to rewrite history, blaming other people, doing
everything we would expect at this point from this
deranged man. This was on his way out to Texas.
So we're going to Texas, we're
going to the southern border,
as you know, we completed the wall.
They may want to expand it. We have the
expansion underway. It's been tremendously
successful far beyond what anyone thought.
We're stopping in large numbers the drugs coming
into the country for many, many years and decades.
We completed the wall and they may want to
expand it. Hold on a second. That doesn't make
sense. The promise was by the end of Trump's
first term, which is seven days from now,
a wall across the entire U.S.
Mexico border. If you did that,
how would you expand it? Would you go into
the water? It doesn't really make sense
and just lie after lie after uncontrollable
and easily disprovable lie. Let's continue.
As far as this is concerned, we want no violence,
never violence. We want absolutely no violence.
And on the impeachment, it's really a
continuation of the greatest witch hunt
in the history of politics. It's ridiculous. It's
absolutely ridiculous. This impeachment is causing
tremendous anger and you're doing it. And it's
really a terrible thing that they're doing now.
Of course, at this point, Trump saying never
violence is silly. It's saying you work
only with fire extinguishers, not matches
after you've already set fire to a house and
it has burned down. And then you say I'm a fire
extinguisher guy at this point forward. Of course,
I'm a fire extinguisher guy. And again, they want
to put the impeachment on Democrats. Democrats
are divisive for considering impeachment. Trump
did the thing that is impeachable and as usual,
the party of personal responsibility, taking
no personal responsibility whatsoever.
Never. I mean, Donald Trump is going
to leave office, never having taken
responsibility for any of his failures.
And he just continues attacking Democrats
for Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer to continue
on this path. I think it's causing tremendous
danger to our country and it's causing tremendous
anger. I want no violence. Thank you very much.
Once again, impeachment causing anger. Recent
poll. Most people want Trump removed, period.
We talked about that earlier this week. The anger
is over what Donald Trump did and his supporters
went into last Wednesday, already angry thanks to
two months of lies told to them by Donald Trump
and Rudy Giuliani and Kayleigh McEnany and
on and on lies telling them Joe Biden stole
this election. Joe Biden didn't really win.
That's why they were angry. And now to say
Democrats are causing anger. Gimme a break, guys.
It's not even it's too ridiculous to even pass the
sniff test and then that. So that was Trump on
his way out once Trump landed in Texas. Again,
we heard from Donald Trump talking to press there,
this time going after big tech. Take a listen.
They're dividing and divisive and they're
showing some things that I've been predicting
for a long time, I've been predicting it
for a long time and people didn't act on it.
But I think big tech has made a terrible mistake
and very, very bad for our country. And that's
leading others to do the same thing. And it
causes a lot of problems that a lot of danger.
So so far, the people to blame right now are
Democrats, media, big tech, still nothing from
Trump on the riotous insurrection he incited
last week in terms of taking any responsibility,
when in reality that's where the primary bulk
of the responsibility is. And once again,
everybody but Trump is to blame. You might also
notice that Trump glitches at the end of this next
clip on the word violence. If you're watching,
you'll you'll again see that spasm like thing that
we've seen throughout his presidency. We still
don't really know much about that big mistake.
They shouldn't be doing it. But there's
always a counter move when they do that.
I've never seen such anger as I see right now.
And that's a terrible thing, terrible thing.
And you have to always avoid violence. And we
have we have tremendous support. We have support
probably like nobody's ever seen
before. Always have to avoid violence.
And then finally, Donald Trump asked about the
capital directly and the speech that he gave,
which said, we're going to go down to the
capital. And here is Donald Trump's answer.
So if you read my speech and many people have
done it and I've seen it both in the papers and
in the media, on television, it's been analyzed.
And people thought that what I said was totally
appropriate. And if you look at what other
people have said, politicians at a high level
about the riots during the some of the horrible
riots in Portland and Seattle and various
other places, that was a real problem, what
they said. But they vandalized my speech and my
words and my final paragraph by final sentence and
everybody just thought it was totally appropriate.
OK, so the speech he refers to is the one
where he said half an hour before the riot,
let's walk down Pennsylvania Avenue and go to
the Capitol and we're going to fight and we'll
never give up and on and on and on. That's
the speech he says was totally appropriate.
So effectively, Trump trying to rewrite history,
taking no responsibility for the riot he caused
while blaming Democrats and big tech
for causing the danger, that speech,
that's not a speech. Those statements are
extraordinarily dangerous. And Trump, of course,
use the word fight or fighting nearly two dozen
times during that speech that he says was fine.
And he said at 12, 30, let's go to the capital
45 minutes later, the riotous insurrection was
starting. Now, in the meantime, as I told you
yesterday, the risk of even more violence is huge.
And so even these, aside from it being
obviously dishonest and completely
ridiculous for the president to try to
rewrite history in this way, we're also
not past the point of danger. According to an
FBI bulletin we've talked about this yesterday,
armed protests like the January 6th protests are,
quote, being planned at all, 50 state capitals
starting Saturday through at least January
20th. And these these are tragic times and
we are almost done with Trump. We're seven days
away, but there is the real risk of more violence
over the next week. And that's something
we all need to be paying attention to